welcome everybody to another developer
update my name is Jeff I'm from the
overwatch development team we're going
to talk to you guys about a bunch of
popular community topics today and I
sort of wanted to go into what is the
team working on right now I know a lot
of people are wondering you know what's
going on we don't always get to hear
from the overwatch development team as
often as we'd like to I need to preface
this by saying not everything that I'm
going to mention is coming out
immediately some of the stuff will come
out in weeks if not months and then some
of the stuff that I mentioned might not
happen at all sometimes in game
development you get pretty far along
with some work and then you realize it's
not working out the way that you want it
to so you end up removing it so I'll do
my best to be clear about what is
definite versus what is maybe anyway
let's start first of all we have a lot
of cool changes that are on our PTR
right now which is our public test
region some of those are balance changes
I know one of the things that almost all
of our players are always wondering
about is you know the balance of the
game and the balance of their particular
favorite hero so there's a lot to look
at on the PTR right now we have some
changes to Widowmaker we've increased
her scope speed you know we got rid of
that old animation cancelling issue with
her scope that was very controversial in
the community but we felt like it was
very important that we didn't have the
ability to min max a power level on a
character based on something obscure
like animation counseling so we're
trying to speed up the scope to make it
feel better without having something
that's not quite understandable to
everybody which is you know the scoping
in and out as quickly as people were
doing before for that you know minimal
power gain and the sort of situational
awareness so far the feedback we're
hearing is that from Widowmaker players
that she feels a lot better we're really
hoping that she becomes more viable and
more played obviously if she's not we'll
continue to look at her and we'll
explore
further changes we have some changes
coming to junk rat strap as well Gangi
can no longer dash through it it used to
be that Genji would dash and destroy it
now again G will get caught in the trap
very similar to how tracer gets caught
in a trap this is both to help with junk
rats viability we hear a lot of interest
in defense heroes being played more and
then also people wondering you know how
exactly am I supposed to counter a
character like Genji not that junk
routes a perfect counter in every
situation but the trap change should
help as well we're also speeding up the
activation time of jug rats ultimate now
there's other questions there's more
changes than that on the public test
region you can read about them on our
website or on our forums if you go to
the community section there are a lot
more changes than that going on but
there are other heroes not immediately
getting changed that people ask us about
often and I want to talk a little bit
about them as well so for example we
hear from a lot of players you know what
about symetra it feels like she's being
left behind I don't see her as much as I
want to or I want to play her more but
when i do my team you know yells at me
to change so we are looking at symetra I
don't think changes for symetra are as
easy as some minor number tweaks that
will have her available and ready for a
play in a changed fashion very soon I
think the types of changes that we want
to look out for symetra might take us a
little bit longer than something like
the Widowmaker scope change which was
relatively small and easy for us to do I
don't have details I know more than
anything people want to know well what
exactly is symmetric going to be when we
come out the other side with her design
iteration it could be um changes to some
of our mechanics and just changing her
overall feel through things like numbers
and cooldowns that's always a
possibility but we're going to look at
some other changes and we're going to
explore some other things as well that
might be a little bit more
dramatic in terms of design vision for
her now what this doesn't mean and I've
seen a lot of this discussion going on
in the community there's a lot of
pushing for symetra to be something that
she's not so a lot of times we see
feedback about you know make it so
symmetric turrets heal people make it so
people get healed if they're near the
teleporter make it so so metros weapon
also heals allies were not really
interested at this time in exploring
symetra as a healer we know that she has
been categorized as a support character
in overwatch but that doesn't
necessarily mean to us that she needs to
be a healer if that means that we have
to move her out of the support care
category we would rather do that then
completely shift the characters designed
to something she was never intended to
be so we're not looking to make symetra
healer what we are looking to do is make
her more viable in more situations I
think right now she's perceived as being
okay or acceptable if you're playing on
defense on a first point or early in a
match other than that we really don't
see symetra as being super viable in a
lot of other situations we know that she
can be effective we've seen her plate
very effectively and she has an
incredible win rate but for the most
part we want to make her less of a
situational pick and more of a you know
hey I really like playing this character
I want to player on offense or defense
and I want to play her in multiple
different situations not just defending
a first point so symetra is something
that we're looking at I would anticipate
the earliest we would see changes in
symetra would be about mid November but
it could be much later than that because
we don't want to rush it we're probably
going to do a lot of internal play
testing and then we would go to the PTR
with her after that so we are looking at
symetra I realize it might not be as
quick as you would like for changes but
she is definitely on our list there's a
lot of other stuff going on so
we've also been looking at our
spectating mode this I'm largely talking
about for eSport broadcasting I know we
have a ton of eSports fans and a lot of
people watching the community
tournaments that are happening right now
in the professional tournaments that are
happening right now and there's a lot of
requests for spectating features there's
a lot of exciting ones on the PTR for
example a commonly requested feature was
to be able to bookmark cameras so you
can go through the maps and you can set
camera locations as a spectator these
are static locations and then you can
use a hotkey to instantly switch between
these different bookmark locations we
also have added a camera that's always
focused on the objective so if it's if
it's an assault map it will always be
focused on the capture point whichever
one is active or if it is a payload it
will focus on the payload and follow it
so this should be really useful for
people who are broadcasting or
professionally spectating to be able to
follow the action more we've also done a
lot of work on the camera to make it
much more steady and fluid it's very
jarring for those of us who like to
watch a lot of eSport if the camera is
kind of jittering or moving around too
much so we've added a lot of smoothing
to the camera that will make it easier
for observers to follow the action and
then we've also added hotkeys for the
observers to focus on specific players
so for example if somebody is playing
tracer in slot too and you hit shift 2
on the PC you will now whether you're
looking at a static camera or that
objective camera it will look through
the eyes of that camera and then be
focused on that tracer and follow her
and if you switch cameras it will also
you know stay on that tracer which is
pretty cool so we think those will be
pretty great improvements now looking
out way far past the media stuff that
I'm that I'm talking about right now a
lot of people are wondering like well
what else is in the pipe so we are we
are actively working
on more heroes right now one hero is
very far along it's coming together
really well we're playtesting it
internally across the entire company and
we believe this hero will see the light
of day sooner rather than later we also
have another hero prototype that we're
extremely happy with right now this one
is in in very internal Developer Forum
is the best way I can describe it we're
using all placeholder models and effects
and animations just to prove out that
the hero is fun but we feel like we
found another really great overwatch
hero that will see the light of day
probably some time next year on that
hero that one's further out than this
one we're also working on a lot of maps
and we maps are interesting to talk
about because we work on a couple of
different kinds of maps we work on maps
for pre-existing modes and we have one
of those that's very far along right now
to the point where we play tested it
enough where we're putting art into that
map now so that means that our level of
confidence in that particular map is
very high like i mentioned that one's
for an existing game mode i think
players will really like both the the
map itself and then also the way it
looks in the story behind it is going to
be really cool we have another map that
is in prototype form that's an existing
game mode map that's much further out
that we're looking at and then we have a
number of maps like I think about four
maps that are prototype developer only
stages of new game modes that we're
experimenting with and it's very
important for me to mention on these
that I don't think all of them will
become actual maps that will end up
launching we we make a lot more stuff
internally on the overwatch development
team than we actually release into the
game often times we find that these
prototypes that we try don't work for
various reasons the main thing that that
sort of steers us away from releasing
some of these
maps and modes that we have internally
is when particular heroes are broken on
them you know for example if somebody
says you know on this map you know
tracer is useless or in this game mode
there's no reason to have tracer there's
no reason to have McCree or whatever
hero might might be the problem will
usually move away from that game mode if
we can't solve the problems we want
overwatch to first and foremost be about
our heroes and not be about gimmicky
game modes but we are really excited and
really actively exploring working on
other game modes and along with them
comes new maps so that's been a lot of
fun for us I'm hopeful that at least a
couple of those new maps and game modes
will see the light of day eventually
they will take us longer to get to than
some of the other stuff but it's
something that the team has a great
passion for and wants to see more of
there's a ton of great ideas both on the
team and in the community so we're
chasing all of that obviously there's a
lot more being worked on than just these
things that I mentioned but I wanted to
talk about the things that I see the
most passion in the community which is
you know new maps new heroes new game
modes kind of wanted to reassure you
guys that we're focused on all these
things in addition to other stuff like
the spectator mode and then there's just
some small quality of life things that
we want to provide for the community in
an upcoming update our hope is to allow
you to unlock things like more voice
lines and more emotes so that's just one
example and be able to use them all at
once and have them equipped so we think
that would be a lot of fun it's a common
feature that we see requested in the
community and we want to be responsive
to stuff like that as well so we're not
only working on the big stuff like new
maps and new heroes but we're also
working on small quality of life
features like that and then we want to
pay attention to our eSports community
and do stuff like the spectator
improvements as well so there's a lot of
stuff going on we know not all that
comes as fast as you would like I just
hope you try
and are reassured in the fact that the
reason it takes so long is because we
want it to be very high quality we want
it to be right when it comes out and we
hope that you know that if it's not
right when it comes out whether it be a
new feature or hero balance that we're
working on this game full time and we
will go back and we will make it right
eventually so that's the update for
today thanks so much for putting up with
my lengthy explanations of everything
and I look forward to talking to you
guys again in the next one
you